وبدا بالسنه للسماء
احنا كده هواء
عندي لسه شويه
اعمل ريفريش مثلا
اوكي
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم يومكم سعيد ان
شاء الله وكل ايامكم سعيده
انا كنت اقول انا في انتظار الاسئله بس ما
شاء الله يعني الاسئله بدات مبكرا
انا طبعا كنت يعني اتمنى في الحلقه دي وفي
حلقات اخرى انه شويه تكون الاسئله مرتبطه
بالموضوعات اللي انتم بتقولوها بحيث يبقى
الموضوع متماسك لكن طبعا انا هتجاوب مع
الاسئله اللي موجوده بقدر استطاعتي احنا
كنا هنتكلم على مرور عام على الحرب
اوكرانيا الحرب طبعا تاثيرها كبير جدا على
العالم وعلى التطورات كتيره خطيره في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
تنذر يعني او تبعث على القلق سواء في
فلسطين المحتله او من جانب اسرائيل برضو
ونواياها تجاه ايران وتطورات اقتصاديه
كتيره لكن تعالوا نبدا بالاسئله بتاعه
حضراتكم
بيقول سلام نريد حلقه على انهيار العمله
في العراق والاقتصاد العراقي بشكل عام
حاضر ان شاء الله في اقرب فرصه حاضر
السلام عليكم فيصل عليكم السلام ماذا عن
زياده بايدن وخطاب بوتين ما هو ده بالظبط
هو يعني
الموضوع اللي انا شاغلني وهو مش محتاج
الحقيقه حل ادم محتاج حلقات كثيره لان
احنا بنتكلم على صراع بيتجاوز رقعه
اوكرانيا عليها الى اسراع بين القوه
الكبرى لو انت حبيت اختصر لك يعني ما
اعتقده وقد اكون على صواب او خطا انا
بعتقد لو عاوز تختار وصف بسيط لهذه الحرب
فتقدر تعتبروها ان هي حرب المسكه او
الحسابات الخاطئه كل طرف دخل هذه الحرب
بحسابات ثبت انها خاطئه ثبت للسيد بوتين
ان
الانتصار السريع على اوكرانيا
وان الغرب التدخله هيكون محدود ثبت انه
خطا والغرب الثبت خطا الكبير في انه
الاستعدادات لقهر بوتين ورضعه عن الغزو او
يعني خروجه
من اوكرانيا سريعا تحت ضغط العقوبات
الهائله ثبت انها خطا كبير ونتيجه خطا
الحسابين احنا قدام حرب بقى لها سنه ويبدو
انها سوف تظل كذلك لفتره طويله
من الزمن يعني ويتسع مداها
وبالتالي سؤال حضرتك خطاب بوتين بيؤكد نحن
مع اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر وخطاب بوتين
بيقول لا يمكن ابدا ان نهزم في هذه الحرب
ولن ينجح الغرب في مسعاه
عزيز هل هناك امل لتحسين اوضاع تونس في
المستقبل ام لا اسف لا يوجد امل ليه لانه
كل الجهود اللي موجوده لا علاقه لها
بالاقتصاد اصلا عشان تقول في امل في تحسين
الاقتصاد التونسي معناها ان انت بدات
وبتتعثر او بتعمل تقدم بطيء اللي حاصل في
تونس زي اللي حاصل في دول اخرى عديده يعني
منها دول مختلفه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
القصه فيها احنا ما بداناش اقتصاد من
الاساس عشان نقول احنا موفقين او غير
موافقين الخلاف كله في تونس الان على شكل
السلطه اللي موجوده والفريق المنتصر
المعركه قائمه من سنوات ويبدو انها سوف
تظل كذلك وحين تستقر يعني الدست او الغبار
هذه الحرب ممكن يبداوا يتكلموا في
الاقتصاد لكن هل الاقتصاد التونسي الصغير
ممكن يسقط على حتى يعني تنتهي الحرب
السياسيه وخلاف الفرقاء وبالتالي حضرتك
السؤال لم يبدا بعد الجهد حقيقي للعنايه
بمشاكل التونسيين الاقتصاديه
انا كان عندي سؤال بس انا يعني احتاج
اجابه من التونسيين لانه انا بطرحها من
بعيد انا عندي انطباع والاقي صراعي
الرئيس التونسي كسب ناس كتيره لانه فاز
لانه عبر عن معارضته لتيار او التيار
بيقوده النهضه لكن في اطراف تانيه كتيره
ثبت انه غير فعال واستفز شريحه على الاقل
واسعه من تونس وبالتالي ده اكسبه وتعاطف
بس الحاجه اللي انا مش قادر افهمها ازاي
الرئيس التونسي ممكن يفكر انه
يحقق استقرار في البلد وانه يظل موجود
وينفذ برامجه اللي هو واثق او يقول انها
في صالح التونسيين وهو يعادي تقريبا
الجميع يعني مسمار مثلا الشهير
المستشار الالماني الشهير كان بياخد
المسائل
السياسيين لما بيواجهوا صعوبات على جبهات
مختلفه بيبدا بجبهه وينتظر الى ان تستقر
الجبهه دي ويفتح جبهه اخرى فتح الحرب على
الجميع
مساله تدعو للاندهاش لكن ربما يكون لذلك
تفسير واهل تونس ادرى بشعابها هل الحكومه
المصريه هتتخرج من الاقتصاد هل هناك ده
عمر هل الحكومه المصريه تتخرج من الاقتصاد
ولا بتراوغ لا بتراوغ
مثل الحكومه كلمه الحكومه المصريه انت
عندك مجموعه من الحكومه المصريه ديت مش
يعني مش بتملك شركه انت عندك ممكن تخرج
الحكومه المصريه النهارده بمعنى ان هي
تقلل تدخلها او
تقلل من وجود قطاع الاعمال اللي هي
الشركات اللي كانت مملوكه للدوله بقايا
القطاع العام اللي انشاؤوا طلعت حرب طبعا
يعني واللي بعد كده تم تاميمه واللي زوده
جمال عبد الناصر واللي ظل عصب الاقتصاد
المصري لسنوات قبل ان يتراجع من بعد سنوات
الافتتاح ده ممكن الدوله تتخارج منه
وتتركه الى مستثمرين
انما في قطاع تاني كبير جدا مملوك لمؤسسات
ضخمه هل ممكن المؤسسات دي تخرج فجاه كده
وتتركه للقطاع الخاص
مساله مش سهله يعني
لكن عموما الاجابه
السريعه انه في توجه عام انه الدوله تقلل
من وجودها وانه بعض شركات المملكه للقوات
المسلحه تبتدي تنقل الى القطاع الخاص مدى
سرعه هذا البرنامج ونجاحه الايام هي اللي
ممكن تحمل لنا الاجابه على هذا السؤال
احمد بيقول لو تطورت الحرب واصبحت حرب
عالميه ايه الفوائد اللي ممكن تحصل عليها
مصر مصر دوله من 193 دوله يا احمد مصر
طبعا انت بتتكلم باعتبارها بلدك وهي طبعا
بلدي يعني
لكن لكن هي الدوله من 193
العالم كله اذا لا قدر الله اشتعل حرب
كبيره فمحدش يقدر ينجو منها وما تقدرش
تحدد دوله بعينها
تقول هتكسب ايه وتخسر ايه لانه في الحروب
بتبقى التوقعات عنيفه جدا لكن ما فيش دوله
تقدر بصفه عامه يعني تقدر تقول انها ممكن
تكسب من اشتعال حرب عالميه لانه لما
بتشتغل حرب عالميه معناها ان الاقتصاد كله
بقى خربان والكل بيعاني وبعدين احنا مش
محتاجين ان احنا نقرا المستقبل قوي لان
التاريخ بيقول لنا كده هل في دول استفادت
من الحرب العالميه الثانيه هل في دول
استفادت اه امريكا كدوله كبيره هل في دول
استفادت من الدول الصغيره من الحرب
العالميه الاولى
هل في امل انه الاقتصاد المصري يتحسن اه
في امل ولكن ليس بالوتيره الا الناس بتحلم
بها
وليس بالسرعه اللي الناس تتوقعها يعني
محمد ربنا يخليك من افضل المحللين واللي
بنستمتع وانا بستمع اليه واحلى سلام ربنا
مني الى ماندو
انا بتكلم على لسان محمد بقى محمود انا
اسف
تحياتي لك استاذ سيد ومندو ربنا يخليك ايه
الاسباب التي تمنع ان كل الدول العربيه
يتحد ويكون دوله واحده هذا السؤال متكرر
واظن منك انت يا احمد
يعني
ما فيش اجابه سهله يعني الدول تتحد يعني
ايه تتحد يعني تتحد بمعنى كلها تبقى دوله
واحده دي فكره تجاوزها الزمن صعب جدا كل
دوله لها حكومه ونخب سياسيه مستفيده من
حكم هذه الدوله
ملهاش مصلحه قوي ان هي تندمج في دوله
تانيه وتبقى
وتتنازل عن نفوذها لصالح دوله تانيه او
النخب اللي في الدوله التانيه تنازلوا عن
نفوذهم في مقابل الاندماج والذوبان في
دوله اخرى
كل دوله فيها نخب مستفيده من الوضع الحالي
غير الحكام يعني
فضلا عن صعوبات كتيره جدا جدا جدا تجربه
الوحده بين مصر وسوريا كانت تجربه صعبه
جدا تجربه الوحده بين اليمن الشام الشمالي
واليمن الجنوبي كان تجربه صعبه جدا تجربه
حتى انا الوحده تجارب التكامل ما كانتش
ناجحه قوي وعندك ادي المغرب العربي
والخلافات اللي موجوده بين الجزائر
والمغرب الان لكن كمان قبل كده كانت ليبيا
ايام معمر القذافي طرف اساسي في هذه
الخلافات الخلافات العنيفه مش الخلافات
العنيفه الخلافات الواضحه بين دول الخليج
اللي بتمنع وجود عمله موحده اللي بتمنع
حتى توحيد
الخطه الامريكيه اللي كانت عاملاها طبعا
هي كانت مقصود منها مواجهه ايران لكن بقطع
النظر عن نواياها ان دول الخليج تحفظت على
فكره وحده الدفاعات الجويه لانه برضو مهما
كانت العلاقات ثقه كل دوله في الاخرى مش
الى الحد انه هو يعني يبقى في وحده دفاع
جوي وتدخل طيرانه واعتقد ان هو طيران صديق
وهو طيران من دوله تانيه لا فكره صعبه يا
صديقي
اسباب الخلاف بين مصر والسعوديه والله لا
اعلم فعلا بامانه مش عارف واعتقد انه ايا
كان اسباب الخلاف انا عارف ان انا قلت سوف
ابحثها ولكن عدى اسبوعين انشغلت باحداث
تانيه كتيره يمكن عدم سبب عدم الاهتمام
بصراحه بامانه يعني ان انا بعتبرها احداث
ماينر يعني احداث بسيطه لانه هي عمليه
سايكلز يعني علاقات قويه جدا يحصل عمليه
خلاف وراء الكواليس يتم التعبير عنه من
خلال الاعلام يبدا الناس يترشقوا اعلاميا
بطريقه مقبوله او بطريقه فجه على الاقل
اللي انا شفته من الصحفيين المصريين كانت
طريقه فاجئه جدا قد يكون فعل ذلك سعوديين
لكن انا لم ارى ده انا مش متابع يعني جيد
لهذا الشان لكن اللي شفته هم زملائنا
المصريين بعضهم يعني
تصرف بشكل بذيء الحقيقه ثم سرعان ما تتحسن
العلاقات وبدا الكلام ده بزياره الرئيس
السيسي كان في المؤتمر العقد في الامارات
وتحدث فيه بشكل للمره التانيه عن السعوديه
والتهنئه اليوم قبل ما ادخل بهواء على
الهواء الرئيس السيسي لولي العهد
والملك السعودي فيعني
يعني كمان انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك في فيما
يتعلق بالدول يعني الخلافات بتحصل كل يوم
يعني هو لو ما كانش حصل تراشق ما بين
الصحفيين اللي هو اكيد مش بريء يعني مش هم
من بنات افكارهم اكيد انا استطيع اجزم انه
ده كان باعاز من من مش منهم يعني من
مسؤولين سواء هنا او هنا على اي مستوى لا
اعلم انما
الدول خلافتها يا خلافات ثانويه هي خلافات
جوهريه تناقضات ثانويه او تناقضات جوهريه
مفيش تناقضات الجوهريه بين السعوديه او
بين دول الخليج ومصر انما بتحصل خلافات
ثانويه ودي التوقف عندها او فهمها مهم
انما يعني حاجه
مش حاجه خطيره يعني
ومع ذلك برضو ان شاء الله تتاح الفرصه
وتكون الاحداث اقل ونعرف ايه اللي حصل ولو
انه اعتقد انه هم تجاوزوه
احييك على حلقه الحرب في اليمن ده ذي اونر
طبعا عمر كان صاحب سؤال الاسباب الخلافه
احييك على حلقه الحرب في اليمن لكن هل
يمكن
هل يمكن مع برود العلاقات بين السعوديه
والولايات المتحده ان يكون هناك مخرج
للحرب في اليمن
هي مش بروده يعني مش سخونه العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده
سخونه العلاقات بين السعوديه المتحده هي
اللي خلقت الحرب في اليمن هي الحقيقه
الصراع السعودي الايراني اللي
بتشارك في الولايات المتحده وحلفاء
اوروبيين
واسرائيل
بنصيب وافر المشكله ليست في العلاقات
السعوديه
الامريكيه المشكله في العلاقات الايرانيه
السعوديه والعلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه
المتوتره مربوطه بعدم شعور السعوديه
بالامان من سياسات ايران وبتعتقد ان هي
بتستهدفها وايران بتعتقد ان السعوديه
واحده من الدول اللي بتسعى لتدميرها
واسقاطها ففي سكيورتي اللي هي ازمه الثقه
بين دولتين ودي بتبقى زي فيديو السيركل
دائره جهنميه كل خطوه الدوله بتاخدها عشان
تعزز امناها بتشعر الدوله الاخرى بالقلق
هكذا دائره جهنميه
بروده بقى العلاقات بين السعوديه
والولايات المتحده لما يمنع الولايات
المتحده من التعاون بشكل معقول من
السعوديه حتى في اسوا فترات العلاقه
البارده اللي حضرتك بتشير اليها يعني
وبعدين انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
السعوديه في حدود معلومات عاوزه تخرج من
بكره بره اليمن لان الحرب طالت من مارس
2015 الى الان الحرب تكلفتها كبيره جدا
على السعوديه ومرهقه وكذا بس المساله بقت
اكبر من مجرد رغبه السعوديه للخروج اولا
في اطراف دوليه زي ما قلت لحضرتك زي ايران
وزي سلطنه عمان وزي دول الخليج الاخرى وزي
الدول الكبيره دول لهم مصالح لكن الاهم من
كده ان بقت الاطراف اليمنيه
مستفيده من الاطراف اليمنيه مش الراجل
اللي هو بيقوم الصبح يروح شغله ويرجع ده
لكن الاطراف اليمانيه النافذه سياسيه
وعسكريا واصحاب
البيزنس مستفيدين من هذا الوضع الموجود
وتاقلموا مع الوضع واستفادوا منه ولا
يمانعوا من استمرار الحرب لسنين طويله
مساء الخير
الخلاف بين قوات فاجنر خلاف حقيقي ولا خدع
للغرب لا ما اعرفش لا اعلم شيئا عن فاجنر
في الداخل يعني
بس يعني يعني
انا ما اعرفش ان في مشكله عنيفه بين انت
عارف شركه امن مملوكه او يعني هي
احد ادوات الحكومه الروسيه
مش عارف ايه الخلاف اللي ممكن يكون منها
بينهم يعني يبقى مؤثر على الاحداث نفترض
ان كان في فصيل انا ما اعرفش القصه اللي
بتحكي عليها يحتاج ان انا اراجعها بس ما
لم يكن هناك شيء كبير جدا انا غير مدرك
ليه اذا حصل خلاف داخل الفصيل يمكن اخراجه
يمكن تحيده من جانب الجيش الروسي يعني دي
جماعات بيتم تكوينها من موالين للحكومه
الروسيه وتابعين ليها ويتم تسليحهم من
موسكو
مساء الخير استاذ سيد انا تقريبا تابعت كل
فيديوهاتك من 2015 وحتى الان بصراحه ما
كنتش متخيل ان في اعلامي زيك في مصر ممكن
تدينا تعليقك على خطاب بوتين وبايدن وليه
بايدن لم يعلن عن الزياره تحياتي لحضرتك
انا ممكن اديك تحيات تعليقي على المجامله
اللطيف شكرا جزيلا بالنسبه لخطاب
بوتين وبايدن انا لسه قايله الاجابه ان
جزء من التصعيد من الدولتين انا قلت يمكن
انت حضرتك ما حضرتش في اول الحلقه انه
الحرب دي
مثل دولي ومثل اقليمي صدام حسين لما بدا
حرب التمن سنوات ضد ايران كانت حسبته انه
دي حرب قصيره سوف يكسر فيها شوكه ايران
ويستعيد الاراضي اللي بيقول ان هي اراضي
عراقيه اخذتها ايران ويكسر شوكتها وربما
يحصل على مزيد من الاراضي الايرانيه وكان
بالنسبه له التوقيت عظيم كل العوامل في
صالح العراق وبالتالي الايران لسه الثوره
قايمه فيها الجيش الايراني شبهه تم حله
يعني
المجتمع الايراني مشغول الى اذنيه في
الثوره الداميه اللي فيها عشرات القتل
اللي قتله في الشهور الاولى مع ذلك كان
اخر ما يتوقعه صدام حسين ان الحرب تستمر
ثمان سنوات
حرب العالميه الاولى بتدرس في الكتب على
انها حرب يعني ما حدش تخيل ابدا اولا
الحرب هتقوم قبلها بشهر ولا شهر ونصف ابدا
ما حدش تخيل ولما بدات الاحداث تتطور بعد
مقتل ولي العهد النمساوي على يد واحد صربي
كده يعني قومي متطرف متطرف بمعنى انه عنده
استعداد يعمل اي حاجه في مقابل يعني
الدفاع عن استقلال صربيا
كان المانيا فاكره الحرب هتكون سهله
النمسا فاكره الحرب هتبقى نزهه كلها حروب
سريعه لكن ما حدش تخيل ان الحرب تستمر
اربع سنوات ثم نتائجها تؤدي الى الحرب
العالميه الثانيه فكانت النتيجه لسوء
الحسابات اكثر من 30 سنه حرب متصله في
اوروبا بصفه رئيسيه وفي كل اطراف العالم
بعد كده في الحرب العالميه التانيه
سوق الحسابات يا صديقي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته لماذا
تدرس الصين تسليح روسيا وكيف سيخدم هذا
مصلحه الطرفين وهل سيعاقب العرض بسوريا
على ذلك اخونا ايزو اذا كان الاسم سليم
اولا تسليح الصين لروسيا هذا اتهام غربي
للروس للتهام الغربي للصين الصين تنكره
حقيقه ما يجري لا استطيع ان اقف عليه
لكن مش هندهش ان الصين تحاول تساعد روسيا
سرا على الاقل بمعدات اللي هي مزدوجه
الاستخدام تستخدم في اغراض المدنيه وفي
اغراض عسكريه ايه اسهل مثال طبعا اللي
تشيبس او الرقائق اللي ممكن تستخدم في
موبايل وممكن تستخدم في صاروخ
مجرد مساعده الصين للاقتصاد الروسي هذا
دعم للمجهود الحربي الروسي لانه الدعم
العسكري او الانتصار في الحرب مش بيقوم
بالصواريخ والدبابات والمدرعات وخلاص انت
عندك الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الدوله
اللي عندها اقتصاد عافي يمكنها من استمرار
العمليات العسكريه على الجبهه
والحفاظ على رضا الناس في
وراء الجبهه يعني
وبالتالي لن يكون غريب يعني ان الصين مش
حاجه غريبه ان الصين تدعم روسيا في مصالح
كثيره مشتركه
[موسيقى]
فده مفهوم
ان الصين هل ممكن كيف سيخدم هذا مصلحه
الطرفين اي طرفين بقى بتتكلم على روسيا
روسيا مستفيده جدا من اي دعم انت مش من
دعم من اي دوله فما بالك لو كان هذا الدعم
مقدم من الصين اللي هي الدوله
العظمى الكبيره يعني اذا الصين وروسيا
كانوا في معسكر واحد صعب ان انت تتخيل
يعني
مواجهتهم بشكل سهل
الصين تستفيد ايه الصين عارفه انه
المواجهه مع الغرب قد بدات مش بالضروره
تبقى مواجهه عسكريه واذا حتى تاخرت
المواجهه الحاميه فانها قادمه قادمه لا
ريب فيها وما فيش افضل للصين ان يكون في
معسكرها دوله بامكانيات روسيا
هل ممكن الغرب يعاقب الصين ما هو بيعاقبها
بس بيعاقبها يعني ايه يعني جزء من قلقوا
من صعود الصين بيحاول يوقف نموها بانه كل
التكنولوجيات المتقدمه المملوكه للشركات
الغربيه تحرم منها الصين والصين بتطور
بدائل
ايه راي حضرتك هل من ضمن اسباب هشاشه
الاقتصاد المصري الان هي الفلوس اللي
سرقها رجال ونظام مبارك لا ما اعتقدش وما
عنديش انا بينه على انه
في سرقات لاشخاص بعينهم غير ما اذنتهم
المحكمه خلاف ذلك لا استطيع ان اتهم حد
بشيء لا اعلمه يعني وعاوز اقول لحضرتك على
حاجه انا طبعا ما اعرفش مين بتقول عليهم
وانا يعني لا يعنيني لا الهجوم ولا الدفاع
عنهم خاصه ان هم ذهبوا يعني
انه الفساد
يعني لوحده كده ان يكون في مسؤول بيسرق مش
كافي ان دوله تبقى ضعيفه لانه الفساد
تقريبا موجود في كل دول العالم ولكن ده
بيكون عامل من مجموعه عوامل كبيره
يعني الاقتصاد ده بيكون هو المحصله انت
حضرتك داخلك بيزيد بيزيد ليه لانه انت
عندك وظيفه موفقه عندك تجاره رائجه عندك
وظيفه موفقه وتجارها ليه بتلاقي مجموعه
عوامل كثيره تعليمك وخبراتك وداديكيشن
والديفوشن بتاعك لعملك وحاجات كثيره
وتوفيق ربنا طبعا قبل كل شيء وحاجات كتيره
بتدخل في الامر وبالتالي
لا مش كفايه ان احنا نختصر المساله في
اللي كان في حاكم وكانوا هو يعني من معه
فاسلين
مندو بوظ البث انت بوظت البث
ما هو محمد القرن هيكذب ليه
ده محمد اللي بيقول طيب خلاص انت يمكن لما
هزيت الكاميرا
انا عاوز اقول لك يا استاذ محمد انه ماندو
قد يكون عميل مزدوج
فهو بيتظاهر بصداقته ويعمل معي لكن الله
اعلم قد يكون بيعمل
حاجات خارجيه هل يمكن ان يحدث الزلزال هل
يمكن ان يحدث الزل هل يمكن ان يكون حدوث
هل يمكن ان يحدث زلزال تغير يحدث في زلزال
تغيرات سياسيه في سوريا وتركيا على وجه
اليقين يا صديقي اونر وهناك حلقه
في اليوم الثالث ولا حاجه زي كده من
الزلزال اعتقد ان هي بتتناول هذا الموضوع
استاذنك ترجع لها من حوالي اقل من اسبوعين
يعني انه بالضروره
واول هذه التغيرات تنعكس على الانتخابات
في تركيا
اول هذه التغيرات هتنعكس على تبخر فرص ان
الجيش التركي يدخل سوريا اول
هذه التبعات
تغير الاولويات للنظام السوري وللن النظام
التركي
لاذنك ارجع للحلقه حتى لا نكرر ما جاء
فيها يعني
ننتظرك يا حبيبنا الله يسعدك والله ربنا
يخليك اخويا طوني شكرا جزيلا رساله طيبه
منك اشكرك
لماذا لا تقوم روسيا بسحق اوكرانيا عن
بكره
اخونا
هي الاجابه ببساطه طبعا هو هو سؤال
الحقيقه مطروح انا ممكن اسمح لي اضيف سؤال
يعني وانت انا هجاوب سؤالك الاول وممكن
اضيف لك سؤال تاني يعني
انه روسيا لديها قدرات عسكريه تستطيع ان
هي تتدمر بها
اوكرانيا
وتدمر بيها اوروبا وتدمر بها العالم عده
مرات انت بتتكلم على حوالي 7000 راس نووي
وبالتالي
داخلها في الاسئله احنا بنتكلم عن السلاح
النووي ما هي عندها في ترسينات احنا ما
بنتكلمش على السلاح الكيماوي ولا
البيولوجي ولا ولا نار الله الموقده ولا
بنتكلم على
النيران التقليديه اللي هي قادره على
تدمير المدن من غير نووي يعني برضو ولكن
يعني ده ما حصلش قبل كده يعني حتى لما لما
الولايات المتحده حربه العراق لما حربت
فئه افغانستان لما شنت حروب على بعض دول
امريكا اللاتينيه ما بيحصلش ان في دوله
تيجي تخرج تدمر يعني بلد بالكامل ده يبقى
حاجه يعني مش مسبوقه ما بيحصلش الكلام ده
ليه ما بيحصلش اديك مثال باوكرانيا هو
داخله اوكرانيا ليه اصلا انا مش هدف روسيا
اولا غير ان هي لو عملت كده هتبقى دوله
معزوله عن العالم كله وتبقى في حاله نفور
منها منين من العالم كله ليه العالم كله
مش امريكا بس ولا اوروبا بس اي حد هيبقى
ضد روسيا لانه اي حد بيشاهد ما يجري بيضع
نفسه مكان روسيا اللي هيكون مكانه روسيا
دوله من اتنين دوله قويه مثلا زي الصين او
دوله ضعيفه زي دول البلطيق الدول البلطيق
مثلا اللي هي قريبه من روسيا تقول لك لما
هي عملت كده في اوكرانيا طب ما انا اللي
جاي بعدهم دول البلطيخ بولندا حتى الدول
الكبيره اقتصاديا لكن ضعيفه اضعف يعني
عسكريا زي المانيا تقول لك تمانه الدور
جاي عليا
طب ولو كانت دوله كبيره وضخمه زي الصين
وزي الهند وزي امريكا يقول لك ما هي لما
هي عملت كده
معنى كده انه اولا ممكن تعمل اولا هي
هتستفيدها تقوى وبالتالي اي قوه للدوله
كبيره يكون على حساب دوله كبيره تانيه وده
منطق في العلاقات الدوليه بيسموه بلانس
اوف باور واللي عليه المثل العربي يعني
انه
الغابه ولا الحشائش لا تحتمل
تحتمل ايه لا تحتمل فحلين او ثورين دائما
يكون هو يعني واحد بس بيقول لك لا انا كده
ده قوه روسيا بانتصارها في حرب معناها انه
اضعاف مني انا فدائما الدول بتراقب
الاجراسر اللي هو المعتدى القوي ودائما
تتحذف ضده للسببين دول اذا كان الدوله
ضعيفه بتقول الدور علي اذا كانت دوله قويه
بتقول
انتصار هذه الدوله سوف يقويها ما يعني
اضعاف لي
اضف الى كل ده بقى ان روسيا دخلت اوكرانيا
ليه اصلا ده دخلت اوكرانيا لان هي مش
عاوزه اوكرانيا اللي بتعتبرها لتر رشا
روسيا الصغيره تكون في المعسكر التاني لان
هي عاوزه
اوكرانيا تبقى دعم ليها دوله تابعه لها لن
تستفيد منها ان هي تدمرها عن بكره ابيها
ومصانعها وبشرها والروس اللي عايشين هناك
اللي هم الاوكران من اصل روسي فهذا غير
معقول يعني
انما طبعا بتبقى في اسئله محيره يعني ليه
الروس عاجزين عن شل الحياه هناك من غير
تدميرها يعني ان احنا بنشوف رؤساء ووفود
بيجوا يزوروا اوكرانيا صحيح بيزوروها
بترتيبات عنيفه وده ردا على السؤال اللي
كان جالي في اول الحلقه ليه بوتين لم يعلن
ليه بيض لم يعلن عن الزياره لاجراءات
الامنيه يقينا انا ما عنديش معلومه مكتوب
الكلام ده يعني بس ما عنديش معلومه اقول
انه الف في المئه لكن يقيني اكتر من الف
ان الرئيس الامريكي لما راح لازم يكون خد
جرين قرض جرين لايت من الروس انه الرئيس
الامريكي هيجي فلا تضربه لانه
الخطا دايما وارد هل ممكن الدولتين
يتفاهموا وبينهم العدوات ديت ما هو بينهم
صفات وبيتفهموا كل الكلام وبيلتقوا على كل
المستويات المعادن الرؤساء يعني
هل لما حصل في سوريا هل لما حصل في سوريا
تاثير ايجابي تاثير ايجابي على مين يا
صديقي
سوريا مش فيها حكومه واحده ومش فيها فئه
واحده
فيها فئات مختلفه بعضها هيستفيد وبعدها
هيتضرر يعني انا النظره القاصره السريعه
اللي هي محتاجه دراسه ربما تكون قوات قصد
كانت الاكثر استفاده اولا الزلزال لم يكن
الاقصى على مناطقها خرجت برضو منظمه اكثر
بحيث انها هي بتعرف مساعدتها على
المعارضه او هيئه تحرير الشام في شمال غرب
سوريا وبتعرض المساعدات على الحكومه في
دمشق يعني ممكن بس تقرلي الاحداث بتتغير
وما تقدرش تقول على المدى البعيد ما حدث
مفيد ولا لا لكن اللي ممكن تجزم به ان ما
حدث زاد ارهاقا وهلاكا لمقدرات الشعب
السوري وزاد الفقراء فقرا وتعؤساء تعاسه
للاسف الشديد
ونسال الله اللطف
تحياتي سيد جبيل المحترم ارجو منك التحدث
اخونا ادم
ارجو منك التحدث قليلا عن مكان دوله
امريكا دول امريكا الجنوبيه في السياسه
العالميه واتجاهاتها ولماذا لا تقوم
بروسيا مثلا بمثل ما تقوم به امريكا
والتمدد لحدودها كما فعلت من قبل مع كوبا
اذا كنت
يعني انت
وصدفه غريبه انا كان يعني النهارده
بيكلمني حد مهم يعني مسؤول مهم في دوله من
دول امريكا الجنوبيه لكن لكن ده ما لوش
علاقه بالدوله يعني ده راجل مشكور يعني
انما انت بتقول ليه هم مش ممكن يتابعوا
ليه مش ممكن روسيا تعمل زي ما عملت امريكا
اتجاه دول امريكا اللاتينيه او الجنوبيه
ودول محيطها يعني زي كوبا باعتبارها
موجوده في الكاريبي يعني طب ما هو ده
المشكله اللي موجوده التناقد في الخطاب
الامريكي امريكا بتقول ان انا ليا منطقه
جوار ونفوذ منها منطقه بحر الكاريبي اللي
هي في كوبا اللي حضرتك الشرق اليها
بامريكا كلها الجنوبيه امريكا الشماليه
اللي فيها طبعا كندا ونتكلم على المكسيك
وكده بتقول من سنه
1800 وشويه 1820 1830 طلع ما يسمى
عقيده مونرو اللي هو الرئيس الامريكي اللي
كان موجود وقتها والعقيده دي بتقول ان
الولايات المتحده لا يجب ان تسمح لاي دوله
اوروبيه باعتبارها هي اللي كانت الدول
الكبيره
بالتواجد في منطقه نفوذها في الامريكتين
الامريكا الشماليه ولا امريكا الجنوبيه
ليه
لانه هي بتعتقد ان وجود اي دوله اخرى في
اي من هذه الدول حتى لو كانت الدول دي
راغبه يمثل خطرا على امريكا
لما والمثل البارز بقى طبعا ما قدرتش هي
تنفس الكلام ده كانت لسه ضعيفه يعني انما
لما بقت قوه عظمى نفذتها ولما كوبا ارادت
ان يكون لها سياسه مستقله بالتقارب مع
الاتحاد السوفيتي حصلت ازمه الصواريخ في
اكتوبر 62
ودي ازمه تستحق ان احنا انا اتكلمت عنها
كتير فمش عاوز اكررها تاني انما باختصار
امريكا لم تسمح لقوب ابدا بحريه التصرف
وان هي تجيب اللي هي عاوزاه من الحلفاء
وتعقد معهم اتفاقات لان ده يهدد امريكا
هي بتقول لها نفس الكلام بتقول لها انا ده
امريكا مش عملت كده دخلت في دول على بعد
الاف الاميال زي العراق وافغانستان وكل
دول العالم بتاعي ان ده يمثل خطر على
ابناء القومي روسيا بتقول لها بنفس المنطق
انا تدخلك في اوكرانيا اللي هي بيننا
الفين كيلو حدود مع اوكرانيا
لا يمثل خطر على يافا تقول لها لا انت كده
بتفردي ارادتك على دول العالم الاخرى وهذا
امر غير مقبول ابدا
عاوز ازيدك من الشعر بيت الرئيس الامريكي
اللي جاء خالف الرئيس ترامب في امور كثيره
لكن من الامور التي لم يخالفوا فيها ابدا
كل ما يتعلق بالامتيازات اللي منحت
لاسرائيل من بين الامتيازات اللي منعها
ترامب الاسرائيل الاعتراف الغير شرعي
والجائر والظالم والمخالف لكل الاعراف
الدوليه بضم اسرائيل
لمرتفعات الجولان طيب
المنطق اللي بيقولوا بيدل ان ضم روسيا
لاوكرانيا لضم روسيا لاقاليم اوكرانيا
يخالف الاتفاقات الدوليه وللن النظام
الدولي وكل الشرائع وكذا على العلم بانه
روسيا ممكن تقول ان في استفتاء يعني هو ده
تم باستفتاء حتى لو الاستفتاء سوري انما
ما حصلش استفتاء في اراضي الكولان والناس
اللي موجودين احنا عايزين ننضم لاسرائيل
وليس لسوريا
فعشان كده في حد كان لطيف بيقول دي هي
ليست ما بين
الدول العالم الحره زي ما بقول بايدن ودول
العالم
الاستبدادي انما هي بين
الدول هو بالامانه قال بين المستبدين وبين
المنافقين انا بعدلها بين الطامحين اللي
هم الروس والصين لتغيير اوضاعهم الى
الاحسن وبين المنافقين اللي هم الولايات
المتحده ومعسكرها
هل لدى السعوديه الامكانيات لتصبح قوه
عظمى لا يا صديقي القوه العظمى تحتاج ممكن
على المدى البعيد في الوقت الحالي القوه
العظمى عشان تكون قوه عظمى لازم يكون
عندها
ظروف اكثر يعني ظروف مختلفه يعني يكون
عندها قاعده تعليميه ضخمه جدا يكون عندها
قاعده صناعيه ضخمه جدا
لازم يكون عندها مشروع محتوي كبير بيشمل
صناعه وزراعه وتعليم وفن وينعكس كل ده على
امكانياتها وتاثيرها في العالم دوله
السعوديه دوله اقليميه مهمه مؤثره عندها
قدرات اقتصاديه كبيره عندها نفوذ ديني
جيد لكن قوه عظمى دي انت بتتكلم على عدد
محدود من الدول هو اللي عنده هذه
الامكانيات لم تعد تتوفر لبريطانيا اسمها
بريطانيا العظمى بس في الاسم لم تعد قادره
لم تعد فرنسا قادره المانيا غير قادره
اللي عنده الامكانيات دي محدود قوي قوي
قوي والدول الكبيره في العالم تعد على
يعني اقل من اصابع اليد الواحده
لحظه
هي كده الاسئله جريت كتير كتير كتير
حد بيقول الصوت منخفض الصوت منخفض يا شباب
انا يعني الاسئله جريت بس هرجع لها تاني
السلام عليكم ده صاله من حامد هل السعوديه
تمتلك سلاح النوويا قولا واحدا لا مش
محتاجه يعني معلومات مش محتاجه سر يعني مش
ممكن اخفاءه يعني عندها طموحات عندها رغبه
دي قصه تانيه لكن سلاح نووي لا ما تعرفش
حد دوله تمتلك سلاح نووي وتخبيه
ابو
سامحني يا ريت تكتب الاسم العربي الله
يوفقك ويخليك جدا جدا محايد ما شاء الله
عليك استمر اخوك الغالي والله يوفقك
ويخليك واتمنى منك الكلام عن اقتصادات
الدول العربيه وتحلول كل اقتصاد وما هو
رابط
بين كل الدول الاقتصاديه احنا عندنا نعرف
اقتصاد وبالمناسبه نعرف اقتصاد
انا طبعا انا تبقى شهادتي مجروحه في
المساله يعني انه اعتقد ان هي ممكن طبعا
هي مش قناه شعبويه ولكن ما يبذل فيها من
جهد والجهد الاكبر يعني
99% هو لصديقي الاقتصاد المميز جدا هاني
جنينه الحقيقه اعتقد انه بيقول كلام يستحق
الاستماع اليه هو
يعني انا عارف انه في طيار كبير يعني
بيميل للحاجات البسيطه اللي هي التعريفات
البسيطه دي انما شويه شويه اولا هي اكتذبت
يعني فئه نخبويه والناس اللي هي ما بتعرفش
اقتصاد لو صبروا شويه هيلاقوا معرفه
حقيقيه في قناتنا اعرف اقتصادي يعني
لكن حاضر يا اخواننا ان شاء الله نتعرف
لاكبر عدد من دول العربيه اقتصاديا يعني
السلام عليكم لماذا يسمح
لماذا يسمح العراق بوجود قاعده تركيه على
ارضه رغم الحكمات التركيه عليه وطموحاتها
في احتلال شمال سوريا واحتلال شمال العراق
كمان يعني بيسمح لايه ما بيسمحش ولا حاجه
بس هو مجبر ما هو لما
ما هي العلاقات الدوليه دي ممكن تفهمها
بكذا الطريقه بس اسهل طريقه فكره انك
تستدعي صوره الغابه مفيش ابدا يعني الغزال
ما بيسمحش للاسد انه ياكله هو بياكله لانه
لازم ياكله يعني
فرائص وطرائد العراق لما كان اقوى ما كان
هو مش بس مش هيسمح لتركيا ده هو هيسمح
لتركيا ولا يسمح لايران بل هو كان بيمارس
نوع من العدوان على الدول الاخرى يعني
فالمساله مش ان هو بيسمح المساله ان هو
بيقول للناس من فضلكم ما تضربونيش من
فضلكم انا بقول الكلام ده وانا متاذي يعني
بس وزير الخارجيه العراقي كل يوم يقول انه
طبعا احنا مش راضيين على الاعتداء على
سياده العراق بس ماذا يفعل يعني
لماذا لا يتم تدمير سد النهضه من القوات
المصريه وما هي توابع التدمير سياسيا وعدم
تدميره داخليه لمصر وما هو مصير مصر من
نقص المياه في المستقبل الجزء الثاني هو
الاسهل مصر وكل الدول منطقه الشرق الاوسط
تقريبا بتعاني من شح في المياه وموضوع
خطير جدا لكنه من الموضوعات المسكوت عنها
لانه انت دايما عندك
مهم وعاجل يعني حتى في يعني المهم قضايا
بتبقى مهمه ويجي عندك
حتى لو كان اقل اهميه بس لا تستطيع ان
تؤجله فالمهم انك توفر الغذاء للناس
العاجل انك توفر الغذاء للناس انك
تتعامل مع حركات مثلا مسلحه هنا هنا اي
دوله يعني لكن في مهم وليس عاجل تغير
المناخي شرح المناخ ممكن يست سنه سنتين
لكن توابعه خطيره لماذا لا يدمر سد النهضه
لانه
ابسط رد يعني
غير ان الوضع تاخر القرار بتاع التدمير ده
كان ممكن يكون في 2012 مثلا 2011 2013 اما
وان السد اقيم واحتجس كميات كبيره من
المياه تدميره معناها تقريبا تدمير
للسودان على الاقل يعني وبالتالي مش مقبول
اتنين ان انت لما تدمر سد النهضه
ما لا يعلمه الكثيرون ان في دول افريقيا
كثيره متعاطفه مع الخطاب الاثيوبي لاسباب
يطول شرحها وبالتالي فكره النتيجه مصر او
اي دوله بتضرب السد ده معناه ان كثير من
دول حوض النيل افريقيا هتبقى الدول معاديه
لمصر
وعليه فانه الازمه ما زالت ازمه
وكل طرف براهن على اعتبارات كثيره يعني
لاحتوائها واحد من اهم الاعتبارات ديت ان
ما فيش مصلحه اثيوبيه يعني في
في ان هي ما تتفهمش مع مصر وان مصر تتفاهم
معها بانه الضرر يبقى مش منعدم ولكن يتم
التقليل منه
وزياده المياه والفيضانات من عند ربنا
قللت من ضغط المشكله انه من تلات اربع
سنين بيجي فقط مياه
الصوت منخفض
منخفض فعلا مزبوط
لباني هو اللي بيقول كده انت السيد الى
اين ذاهب الوضع في لبنان في رايك
ده علي مراد علي انت كنت بتتواصل معي عليه
انا اذكر اذا كان الاسم يعني سليم يا ريت
تاكد ليه
ايه رايك انت على الوضع في لبنان رايح فين
عامل زي الوضع في
في دول المشكله بتتجاوز
بتتجاوز حجم المعقول انا قلت انا يمكن
اجبت نفس السؤال ده يعني وضع السرياني
الوضع السرياني ده بيكون ناتج عن انه
الدول بالحكومات دايما في ازمه بحكومات
سيئه بتبقى في ازمه اكبر
من غير حكومه اصلا عامله زي الصداقه اللي
كان بيسال عن الاقتصاد في تونس ما هو اصلا
ما بداوش علاج الاقتصاد عشان نقول هيبقى
فيه امل ولا لا فالوضع في لبنان طبعا يعني
السلام عليكم
بيتكلم وما هي الافق المتوفره للوضع في
لبنان لا الوضع في لبنان لو عاوز اجابه
تاني وتالت ورابع مش مرتبط باراده بس
القوى المحليه اللي موجوده في لبنان هو
مرتبط هو مرخوم باراده الدول الاقليميه
والدول الكبيره مش هيحصل
هدوء في الوضع اللبناني مش هيحصل هدوء في
الوضع العراقي مش هيحصل هدوء في الوضع
السوري ولا في الوضع اليمني ولا في الوضع
الليبي
الا لما تهدى الاوضاع بين الاطراف الدول
الكبيره في الاقليم والدول الكبيره بقى في
العالم
ابسط واهم مشكله يجب حلها هي الصراع مع
ايران واحد ثم الصراع طبعا بين روسيا
والغرب يعني
طالما انه هذه الاطراف الصراع مشتعل بين
ايران وكل فرقائها وما بين روسيا طبعا ده
الاول الاساس لانه كان موجود حتى قبل
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وزادت المشكله
بالصراع ما بين
روسيا والغرب والتوتر ما بين الصين بالغرب
ما هو ده اللي كان حصل في الحرب البارده
من سنه 47 48 لغايه سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
حرب بارده ضحايا يعني ايه بارده يعني
بارده ان الدول الكبيره ما بتشتبكش عسكريا
فيما بينها لكن بتحارب على حساب الدول
الاخرى ديت بتنشر فيها الاضطرابات تسقط
حكومات
تحاول تقوم حكومات يعني
تدعم حكومات ضد اراده شعبها او ضد اراده
الدول المجاوره
هل ممكن تشرح لنا لاخونا محمد جمال الفرق
بين اوكرانيا ودول البلطيق بالنسبه لروسيا
مع ان دول البلطيق دخلت حلف النيت وسبق
سبقا مع ان الدول البلتقط ايوه ما هو هو
عاوز جمال يسال ليه
دول البلطيق التلاته ليتوانيا
ولو فتحت عليهم الخريطه هتلاقيهم ثلاث دول
صغيره كده موجودين على بحر البلطيق في
مواجهه روسيا
وطبعا اقليم كليلين جراد اللي هو الروسي
اللي مش موجود في روسيا موجود في ضهرهم
اقليم
فهتلاقي ان الدول الثلاثه دول لما دخلوا
حلف شمال الاطلسي في 2004 روسيا ما عملتش
حاجه لكن لما اوكرانيا فكرت ان هي تتقارب
على امل ان هي تدخل حلف شمال الاطلسي في
المستقبل روسيا غازتها الفرق وببساطه ان
روسيا في 2004 ما كانتش قادره ان هي تعمل
حاجه زي ما كانتش قادره ان هي
يعني مثلا في
روسيا كانت ضد حرب غزوه لامريكا العراق في
2003 لكن كل اللي قدرت تعمله ان هي تعترض
ظروفها ظروف قبلها حرب الشيشان
الثانيه كان مخليها مش قادره هي تدخلت في
جورجيا المهمه كانت سهله في 2008 كانت
بدات تتحسن الاوضاع بالنسبه للروس روسيا
روسيا الاتحاديه كانت خارجه بظروف صعبه
جدا من انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي في اخر 91
بعد كده جت ازمه اقتصاديه كانت في روسيا
تعلن افلاسها في 98 99
بدات الاضطرابات تقل وجاء الراجل بايدن
اللي راجل بوتين اللي تختلف تتفق عليه انه
كان من مزايا ما فعله انه عاد الاستقرار
بدا روسيا تطلع من الاضطرابات وتبقى دوله
معقوله فدوله قادره فدوله قويه فدوله قويه
جدا الى اخره اول ما بدا يسترد انفاسه بدا
يعيد النظر في كل ما حدث في مقررات الحرب
البارده ونتائجها في تغول حلف شمال
الاطلسي وبدا على طول من 2008 انه يتدخل
في جورجيا يمنعها من الدخول لحلف شملاء
الاطلسي ثم تدخل في 2013 و2014 ضد الثورات
اللي كانت معموله
علشان يبقى في تغيير يعني الربيع
الاوكراني في 2014 ثم دخل
جزيره القرم واستردها كامله من اوكرانيا
ثم بدات الحرب من 2014 من الحرب اللي
موجوده ديت بادئه من 2014
هذا هو السبب يعني الفرق قوه روسيا وليس
انه المبدا هي كانت تتمنى طبعا ان دول
البلطيق لا تدخل
هل بوتين يحارب الماسونيه الان ام يساهم
في الانهيار الاقتصادي من اجل النظام
العالمي الجديد اخي العزيز انا لا اعلم ما
هي الماسونيه التي يشير اليها الكثيرون
انا عملت في بدايه الحلقه 3 حلقات عن
الماسونيه في الارشيف القديم يمكن لو بحثت
عنهم سوف تجدهم بس كلمه الماسونيه كلمه
عامه بدل كلمه الماسونيه خلينا نقول انه
بيحارب اعداءه الواضحين يعني الماسونيه
كلمه فضفاضه قد تكون دقيقه قد تكون غير
دقيقه في في تقدير يعني وصف اعدائه
بالماسونيه كلمه ممكن تشتت الانتباه
وتدخلنا في تفاصيل مش واضحه يعني انما هو
بوتين بيسموه تعرف حضرتك كلمه اللي هي
يعني مراجعه حط لها
تبقى دوله
بتعيد النظر في وضعها الحالي وعاوزه
تحسنوا تحسنوا ليه لان هي بتعتقد ان
حقوقها اكلت حين ضعفت
والكلام بيجيب بعضه العراق حين ضعف اكل
حقه لو استرد العراق قوته هيعيد النظر في
امور كثيره جدا وهيبدا يحاول يبص لدول
الجوار ودول الجوارها تعتبره دوله مفترسه
مره اخرى
كذلك ده مش خاص بالعراق مش خاص بروسيا ده
طبيعه الاشياء افتكروا صوره الغابه اللي
بيقوى بياكل الاصغر منه ده طبيعه قانون
البقاء اللي يقدر ياكل الاصغر بياكله
فروسيا ضعفت فاكل حقها قويت فبدات تطالب
بحقها قويه اكثر فبدات كمان تستخدم القوه
المفرطه ضد جيرانها
عشان تحافظ على امنها يعني
لماذا لا يستخدم بوتين السلاح النووي احنا
اجبنا السؤال ده لماذا لا تقوم روسيا بسحق
اوكرانيا هو ده السؤال برضو يشبه السؤال
بتاع اخونا الجو
الصوت منخفض ده نفس التعبير بس انا اعتقد
ان هو قديم رايك فيه مشروع المربع الجديد
الذي اعلن عنه ولي العهد السعودي لا اعلم
عنه الا انه بيحاول يعمل داون تاون كبير
وسياحي لا اعلم عنه اكثر من ذلك وده بتبقى
بطبيعه الحال بياناتك عن انه الدوله ربنا
يزيدها يعني كمان وكمان عندها فوائد لما
يكون عندك فوائد بتصرف بيبقى في مشروعات
تعتقد ان عائدها هيكون على المدى البعيد
ويتحسن رفاهيه مواطنين وتعمل طفره وكذا
بعض هذه المشروعات بيكون مفيد وبعضها
التاريخ بيقول انه مش مفيد لكن السبب
الاساسي هي فوائد البترول اللي خلت
الميزانيه يبقى عندها الميزانيه السعوديه
اكتر من 80%
وبالتالي ده هو السبب اللي بيخليه يعمل
هذه المشروعات اما المشروع نفسه فلا اعلم
الا ما اعلنت عنه الحكومه السعوديه انا
هطور
وسط البلد بشكل رياض بشكل كبير جدا هذا ما
سمعته يعني اتمنى يوفقه
هل يمكن لدوله ان تعيش دون قروض
ما سمعتش يعني
دوله تعيش بدون قروض يعني هل هو اصلا
مطلوب يعني ان انت ايه ما فيش حد بيتكلم
ما حدش بيقول في الاقتصاد ان القروض وحشه
امال الناس بيقولوا ايه
انت عاوز تاخد قرض انت هتاخد قرض ليه
الاول معناها ان انا دلوقتي سايبه مثلا
انت سيادتك عندك مشروع المشروع ده عاوز
تبداوا عاوز تعمل مصنع ينتج اقلام انت راس
مالك مش مكفي عشان تعمل المصنع ده فانت
بتقول انا هحط عشره وهجيب كمان من البنك
عشره وابتدي انتج اقلام فالمصنع يربح انا
استفيد اسدد العشره للبنك وابتدي ان انا
احقق ارباح ده جميل جدا
دايما الناس بيقولوا القرض في حد ذاته ليس
سيئا لانه بيختصر لك الزمن ما انت لو
استنيت لما يبقى عندك العشره التانيين
ممكن عمرك كله يروح
ناس بيقولوا القرض بيكون كويس لما بيكون
الهدف في استخدامه رشيد ولما بيكون في
الحدود اللي انت قادر على سداده وكذلك
الدول الدوله بتاخد قرض بتعمل به ايه
وقادره على سداده ولا لا والاتنين مرتبطين
ببعض انت بتقدر تسدد لو خدت القرض ده
وحطيته في مشروعات تنمويه هل ده بيحصل في
الدول مش لا مش دايما بيحصل ليه ما بيحصلش
عشان انت لما بتيجي تاخد اولا الكلام ده
سهل ان انت تقوله بيجي واحد يتولى حكم
البلد اللي بيحكم البلد ده بينتمي لفصيل
كبار يا دوله ديمقراطيه عندها انتخابات
وشفافيه هي دوله ديكتاتوريه ما فيهاش
انتخابات او لو فيها انتخابات مش مهمه
الاتنين النتيجه في الجانب ده واحد اللي
في حكومه ديمقراطيه بيبقى عنده مسائله
اكبر بس عنده حافز انه يقترض وينفق على
الناس ويبسطهم علشان هو يقعد اربع سنين او
خمس سنين او ست سنين عاوز ينتخب مره تانيه
فبيبقى عاوز ينفق اكتر ودي مشكله سقف
الدين في الولايات المتحده دايما الحكومه
عاوزه تنفق مش عاوزه تصدر مشاكل لناس مش
عاوزه تحطهم تحت ضغط عشان تفضل محبوبه
وتنتخب مره تانيه واحد زي بايدن حتى لو هو
ادى فترتين وهيمشي هو مسؤول عن حزبه اللي
عاوزه يفضل فيه السلطه وبالتالي بيخدم على
جماعته لو كان في حكومه مش ديمقراطيه هو
موجود في السلطه الان ويامل انه يفضل في
السلطه الى ان يتوفاه الله فعاوز مش يضايق
الناس عاوز يصدر مشكلته لابعد وقت ممكن
وبالتالي يعني
الديون مش هي المشكله تستخدم الديون ازاي
وتسيطر عليها ازاي هي المشكله
وطبعا في ناس حقيقه يعني بيتحطوا في ظروف
صعبه يعني بيجي يعني انت تونس انت
بتتكلموا على تونس تونس لما تهدى فيها
الاوضاع نفترض جالها احسن حاكم في العالم
والعالم توافقت عليه لما يحول يعني هيبدا
الحياه ازاي هو ما عندوش اي فلوس هيبدا
بها اي مشروع الا ان يقترض في الاول فاضل
بس انه يقترض الاول علشان يمنع الاضطرابات
الاجتماعيه عشان ينفق على الناس اكل وشرب
لازم هيعمل كده والا لو ادى كل الفلوس
لمشروعات طويله الاجل ناس مش هتصبر عليه
برضو يعني
هو كان في سؤال هل ممكن ماذا يحدث للعالم
لو امريكا توقفت عن الديون ورقه جاده
اتعملت ورق الدراسه وجدت ان الاقتصاد
العالمي يتاثر بشده يعني لان في
بزنس كبير قايم على اقتراض الحكومه
الامريكيه اللي هو اكبر
اقصد في العالم
استاذ السيد الى هل
محمد الحسن بيقول الصوت منخفض
ست منخفض يا شباب انا سامع تعليقين
بيقولوا الصوت منخفض
مظبوط مش بقول لكم ماندو
رايك فيه مشروع اجنه السلام
هل يمكن
هل يسمح بوتين بانكسار روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
مهما كانت دعم الغربي وباي ثمن
طب انا فهمت السؤال بس ما فهمتش
العلامه اللي انت عاملها يعني حد يعني انت
كده مبسوط ولا بتضحك ولا ايه موجي بيسموه
ولا
ايموجي الايموجي اللي انت حاطه انا مش
فاهمه يا خالد لكن على العموم هما يسمح او
لا يسمح اكيد هو لن يسعى لذلك لكن
اذا هزم مش هيكون هزم لانه سمح هيكون هزم
لانه فشل في مهمته يعني
ولو ان ده مش هيكون مساله سهله يعني بدنا
حلقه عن انهيار العمله في لبنان لو سمحت
حاضر يا علي
هل الحرب وارده بين الصين وامريكا ام فقط
مجرد تهديدات هي صعبه ان الاتنين يفكروا
فيها وهم كامل يعني في كامل ليقتهم
العقليه ايا كان اللي بيحكم البلدين لكن
الاخطاء وارده
احنا كنا بنتكلم ان حروب كثيره حصلت بسبب
المسكه الكوليشن او سوء التقدير وسوء
التقدير دايما
حارث وحرب اوكرانيا مثال واضح جدا على ذلك
يوسف بيل حذف الرساله ماذا حذفت يا يوسف
طيب مات بيقول متابعك
مديء مش عارف اقرا ما تداعيات انسحاب
بوتين من اتفاقيه ستارت 2 هل صحيح ان
الصين بدات بدعم روسيا عسكريا ماذا سيحدث
وانا ما اعرفش ان هو انسحب وقال انا جمدت
الاتفاقيه اللي بتنظم عدد الصواريخ
اظن متوسطه المدى
لان في اكتر من ستارت يعني لكن الاتفاقيه
التي تنظم الصواريخ
بين الدولتين الاكبر النوويا
قام بوتين بتجميدها وكان حريص في خطابه
نقول انني لم انسحب منها
وعلى فكره في حلقه كانت مع الدكتور يسري
ابو شادي لما كنا متوقعين انه الدولتين
هيلتقوا في القاهره من حوالي اربع او خمس
شهور وتم الغاء الاجتماع يا ريت تكتبوا
عليها كده معاهده ستارت 2
مع وجود النووي الاسرائيلي هل توجد وسيله
رضع عسكريه مصريه مقابله للنووي يعني حسب
حلقه سابقه كانت اسرائيل مستعده لضرب السد
العالي بالنووي يعني في حرب مستقبليه
مصريه اسرائيليه ايه هيكون رد مصر
يعني
بتتكلم على سيناريو كارثه يعني حرب
ويستخدم فيها النووي معناها انه الحرب
وصلت الى مستوى مهول جدا وانه
الاسرائيليين احدق بهم تماما وانه اصبح
ضهره للحائط فهو دايما العقيده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وده ممكن يجررها الموضوع
اسرائيل لموضوع روسيا بيستخدم السلاح اللي
هو السلاح اللي هو الملاذ الاخير لما مش
بس بيعجز وبيبقى ضهره للحائط وانه خلاص
بقاءه على المحك
لانه دي كيان صغير محدود عمقه مكشوف اي حد
ممكن يهدده اي حد زي مين ما حزب الله
هزموا في 2006
على كل جبروته وعلى كل اسلحته لما بتبقى
جامعات المقاومه بتستطيع انت طالق كل
مساحته يعني
وبالتالي ايه قوات الرضع لا قدر الله اذا
اندلعت الحرب انت عندك الربع الفارق
الفارق الكبير في الحجم الفارق الكبير في
العدد الفرق الكبير في الاسلحه حجم
الاسلحه وقدره
يعني الدوله زي مصر او الدول اللي معها
على الحق ضرر باسرائيل
يعني اقرب الى موجود يعني في كتب بتتكلم
عليه الى اخره بس يعني سيناريو تخيلي شويه
الجزائر مقاطعه فرنسيه
انت عاوز تقول كده ماشي
السلام عليكم ما رايك وجبنا كيف استوعبت
اسرائيل تحقيق اهدافها في فلسطين والحصول
على الاعتراف الدولي وكيف لدوله واحده
صغيره لا يتجاوز عدد سكانها تسعه ان تلعب
على 22 دوله عربيه والى اخره ده سؤال يا
اخونا هاني يعني
يعني عاوز حلقات بس هل ممكن استاذنك ترجع
لحلقه بعنوان على ما اذكر لماذا يخاف
الرؤساء الامريكان من اسرائيل انا اظن انه
يعني انا بذلت فيها جهد
يعني كان كبير واظن يعني الحمد لله وفقت
في اجابه على سؤالك الى حد ما والاجابه دي
بتقول ازاي اسرائيل دي لها كل هذا النفود
على الولايات المتحده وعلى دول غربيه اخرى
بالاضافه بقى انه يعني في حلقات تانيه
بتتكلم على اسباب القوه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
وفي حلقه تانيه اللي هي حرب 67 استاذنك
ترجع لها حرب
بتتكلم على ليه اسرائيل انتصرت في الحرب
دي فاستاذنك ارجع للحلقتين دول واذا لاي
سبب وجدت صعوبه في البحث عنهم ابعث لي
وانا ان شاء الله هبعتهم لك رابطين بس ما
اعتقدش ابدا ان في اي صعوبه في انك تجدهم
لولا انا خايف انا دلوقتي يروح كنت عملت
بحث سريع
وطلعتهم لك يعني
ممكن يلاقوها بعد اللايف في الحلقه
ريكوردز فوق ما هو بعد بس انا بلاقي حلقه
واحده اللي ممكن احطها هو عاوز اكتر من
حلقه لكن
ممكن طيب انا هحاول احطها ان شاء الله
كمان لحضرتك بعد
بعد الفصل بس هم موجودين هنا واثق انه لو
كاتب 1967 او حرب 67 هيلاقيها واثق ان
العنوان انا فاكره كويس لماذا تخاف
اسرائيل من الحكام الاسرائيليين في
الحلقتين اعتقد هتلاقي الاجابه على سؤال
حضرتك
في كمان حلقه لو انت مهتم بالشان
الاسرائيلي
اللي هي السؤال الذي
يعني السؤال الوحيد اللي الاسرائيليين
قالت اليهود لم يجيبوا عنه اللي هو وضع
الفلسطينيين انا مش فاكر العنوان الحلقه
الحقيقه بس بغض النظر عن السؤال هو انت
هتعرف فيه مين اللي كان واقف ورق قيام
الدوله اليهوديه او الاسرائيليه ومن
البدايه هم جايين على ان هم قوه كبيره
تجمعت من دول تانيه علماء عسكريين الى
اخره
محسن افضل قناه يوتيوب ربنا يخليك السلام
عليكم
جابنا هل
استاذ الصين حريصه
على الا تنزلق في حرب لان التوجهاتي
اقتصاديه بحته هل تتفق
هي مش بس عشان كده يعني انت
اولا هو في حلقه بتتكلم على موقف الصين من
الحرب
اعتبارات الصين متعدده
ابسط اجابه مباشره لحضرتك ان انا كصين
كدوله كبيره مش معقوله ان انا الدوله
تانيه ليا بها علاقه طيبه فهي حرب فانا
حارب معها
ده كلام مش منطق حتى في البلدان اللي
بينهم
اتفاق دفاع مشترك الدفاع المشترك ده بين
اي دول لو كان موجود زي مثلا حلف الناتو
بيقول لو انت اعتدى عليك انا انضم اليك
لكن نفترض مثلا انه فرنسا قررت ان هي تشن
عدوان على
دوله مثلا راح اتضرب الدوله في افريقيا
بتاعتها مش حلف شمال الاطلسي مش مطالبه
انضم اليها انت خرجتي وروحت ضربت دوله هذا
امر يخص هذا اولا ثانيا الصين عندها
حسابات معقده هي لا تريد ان تخسر روسيا
ولا تريد ان تبارك الاتفاق برضو لا تريد
ان تبري غزوها لاوكرانيا هي غاضبه من
غزوها لاوكرانيا ولم تبارك لم تدنه ولم
تصوت بالتاييد عليه ولكن هي موقفها انه
يجب الحفاظ على سياده الدول ليه لان هي
بتحب اوكرانيا لا
لان هي بتعتبر انه ده هيكون موقف في
المستقبل بتقول انه يجب الحفاظ على سياده
الدول يعني يجب الحفاظ على سياده الصين في
تايوان اذا هي باركه
الاعتداء الروسي على اوكرانيا اللي هو
مبني على انه عباره عن تدخل لنصره
في المقام الاول الروس اللي موجودين
والدول اللي اعلنت استقلالها في شرق
اوكرانيا
وبناء على انه يعني ده العامل الاولاني
وبالتالي هتبارك التدخل الغربي
للانفصاليين اللي موجودين في تايوان لا
اسباب كتيره ثم انه ايرلي هي عارفه ان في
مواجهه مع الغرب يا ريت ما تجيش لكن اذا
جت بلاش دلوقتي هي تعلمت من درس المانيا
ودرس اليابان الدول اللي هي بتبقى صاعده
وتتحدى القوه القائمه وتنهار فلا هي عندها
حساباتها وتعتقد ان المواجهه اذا كانت
حتميه يبقى مش دلوقتي
وبعدين هي مستفيده كمان يعني الى حد ما كل
دوله مستفيده ومتضرره برضو هي مستفيده
دلوقتي مش مستفيده يعني
يعني هي قطعا لن تفكر في ان هي تنضم الحرب
وان هي تعادل الغرب اللي هي الاولويه
الاولى لكشريك تجاري انما يعني اذا كانت
روسيا مصره على الحرب يبقى ممكن تستفيد
يعني تستفيد في شكل انه الروس هيبقوا طوعا
لها في المستقبل
هل من الممكن نظريا وعمليا لحماس والفصائل
الفلسطينيه اعلان سلطه موازيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه من طرف واحد مع الياس من حكومه
وحده مع السلطه ما هم عاملين كده ما في
حكومه غزه وحكومه الضفه يعني هم عاملين
كده للاسف يعني
هل سيسمح بوتين
جابناه تاني
اخونا اللي قال ليه ما يستخدمش السلاح
التكتيكي في اوكرانيا ويخلصنا احنا اجابنا
السؤال ده
ممكن تشرح لنا الفرق بين جبنه
محمد علي ما هو الوضع الاقتصادي والسياسي
لمصر على المدى القريب
عده مرات يعني على فكره في حلقه النهارده
ان شاء الله يعني هي موجوده انا بس يعني
كان اليوم طويل جدا حلقه بتتكلم على موضوع
الصكوك الاسلاميه اللي اصدرتهم مصر
النهارده لاول مره في تاريخها استاذنكم
تبقى تشوفوها بعد انتهاء الحلقه بمجرد ما
اخلص ان شاء الله يعني على الساعه عشره
مثلا او قبل عشره كمان ان شاء الله نكون
ادعناها
ممكن جواب عن وضع العراق والى اي محور
اقرب هل ايران وروسيا والصين امام امريكا
لا
السؤال مش كده وضع العراق وضع سيء جدا
هنتكلمنا عنه من شويه
وهو مش قادر انه يحتفظ
بسياسه خارجيه تخص بيحاول يرضي الجميع
لانه في وضع لا يستطيع ان يعادي احدا
وبالتالي لا هو مش مع حد هو مش عاوز يبقى
مع حد اصلا لان مع حد يعني هتعادي حد
وتعادي حد يعني انت تكون قادر على
المواجهه
هل
نريد حلقه عن اقتصاد الجزائر ان شاء الله
استاذنا المتواضع
هل من مصلحه المغرب نهج سياسه الطريق
المسدود مع فرنسا
افريقيا
موضوع اخونا دهبين موسى اخونا رابين موسى
التوتر في العلاقه مع مره مع اسبانيا ومره
مع فرنسا ومع دول اخرى يعني هو بالنسبه
للمغرب هي واحنا يمكن قلنا الكلام ده كتير
يعني هي بيهمها انه الدوله رقم واحد
واتنين وتلاته تبارك لان الروس المغرب في
حاجه انه اول مره يحصل انفراجه بالنسبه
لامريكا وتعترف المغربيه في عهد ترامب
بمغربيه الصحراء ده كان امر غير مسبوق
وسبق ذلك ارخاصات وتبع ذلك ان دول بدات
طبعا عمل ده في مقابل التطبيع مع اسرائيل
مجرى الرئيس بايدن مش عاوز يعني معترض على
القرار بس القرار يمس اسرائيل فهو مش عاوز
يسلب من اسرائيل اي ميزه منحت لها
المسؤولين في المغرب في بيدفعوا بالحاح
شديد له حسم قضيه الصحراء وبالتالي من بين
الوسائل اللي بيعملوها الضغط على اي دوله
لا تؤيد موقفهم 100% فيما يتعلق بالصحراء
اذا فرنسا تجاوبت معها اوكي اذا لم تتجاوب
معها التوتر بيروح وبيجي يعني مش ان في
يعني
يعني مش في تناقضات عنيفه بينها وبين
فرنسا يعني
انا اعتقد ممكن كمان سؤالين
عندنا اسئله كتير ولا كده خلاص
لماذا فرنسا خائفه من علاقات علاقه المغرب
مع اسرائيل خاصه انها اشترط ان تقطع
العلاقات ان تقطع العلاقات المغرب
واسرائيل لكي تستانف علاقتها المغرب انا
ما اعرفش المعلومه دي يا محمد معرفش ابدا
ان فرنسا طلبت من المغرب
قطع العلاقات مع اسرائيل لو عندك مصدر
للمعلومه اكون شاكر جدا جدا انك تبعته لي
واسهل طريقه ان انت تبعتها لي اذا ما كانش
الاجابه حاضره ان انت تبعتها لي على رساله
على الصفحه العامه على فيسبوك يا ريت بس
انا اشك في هذه المعلومه لكن اذا كان عندك
مصدر قوله لي يعني
السلام عليكم ما رايك في الوضع عجبناه
حضرتكم ما بتتكلمش عن السعوديه ليه ولا هم
ولي
ولي نعمتك حضرتك مش فاهم السؤال طب ولما
يكون ولي نعمتي يبقى انا اتكلم عنه ولا ما
اتكلمش عنه
يا اصدقائي الاعزاء انا طبعا يعني كل
الشكر ان انت مهتم وحاضر الكلام اللي هو
الخشن ده ما يبقاش ليه معنى يعني انت هل
انت معتقد يعني لما تقول الكلمه دي انت
انت عندك غضب في اي سبب من السعوديه ولا
شخص البطاله ده لما تحط السعوديه ده خفف
من غضبك يعني
انا بقول كده لانه كلامك مش مبني على حاجه
يعني ما فيش حاجه انا مش كل يوم بتكلم مش
مثلا في مصيبه في السعوديه وانا سايبها
ولا انا كل يوم بمدح في السعوديه
فالكلمه مش فاهمها يعني ومع ذلك
الله يكون معك رايك في مشروع لا اعلم
في مشروع المربع الجديد متى ستستعيد مصر
دورها المؤثر في الشرق الاوسط وده مرتبط
بقوه البلد انت البلد بيبقى عندها قوه
كبيره لما يكون عندها وسائل السوفت باور
اللي بيقولوا عليها القوه الناعمه اولا
السوفت باور ديت والقوه الخشنه القوه
الخشنه يبقى عندك قوه عسكريه كبيره وعندك
الاقتصاد تعتبره قوه خشنه ولا قوه ناعمه
يكون عندك قوه اقتصاديه كبيره عندك قوه
صناعيه عندك زراعه عندك ثقافه منتعشه عندك
نموذج الدول اللي حواليك بتحاول تقلده
بحيث ان هي تبقى مشدوها ليك وبتسعل تقليدك
يبقى في الفن وفي الرياضه وفي الثقافه وكل
حاجه عندك نموذج منور ولامع فالناس بتروح
له زي كان نموذج امريكا في الخمسينات
والستينات والسبعينات مثلا يعني زي نموذج
الصين اقتصاديا الناس يقول لك عاوزين نقلد
نموذج الصين زي زي الى اخره يعني فانت
هتستعيد نفودك لما تستعيد وسائل قوتك
الناعمه والخشنه
سوي حلقه عن اقتصاد تونس حاضر هل السلام
ممكن ده عمر بيقول ممكن حلقه مع سياده
السفير
عن ما كان يحدث وراء الستار وشكل العداء
بين مصر واسرائيل بعد كام
وماذا كان يحدث وراء الستار والله بكل
سرور حاضر هو انت بتتكلم على السفير رفعت
الانصاري هو حابب يعمل قناه وانا بشجعهم
يعمل قناه وان شاء الله يعملها وان شاء
الله نستضيفه في حلقات ويجاوب سؤال حضرتك
استاذ الى اين لا اجبني سؤال دعالي مراد
بيتكرر هل تقول ان بوتين في مرمى جنرالات
الروس لا هل نقول لا انا انت عاوز تقول
براحتك ده البرق الخاطف انا اصل انت
الكلام الكتير اللي بيتقال على بوتين
متاخد من الاعلام الغربي الذي يجب ان تكون
حذرا في تناوله بعض مغرض بعضه عادل ومنطقي
وبعده بيعبر عن امنيات انه نفس روسيا كلها
تختفي يعني
هل ممكن تشرح لنا لماذا تقوم روسيا اعجبنا
هل
سلمت مصر باقتطاع جزء من حصتها بالمياه
لاثيوبيا لا هي لا هي سلمت ولا اثيوبي
قالت ان هو يقتطع اثيوبيا بتقول ان
التاثير محدود جدا ولفتره مؤقته
[موسيقى]
هل يمكن اندلاع حرب بين المغرب والجزائر
ده قناه منوعات هو داخل بالاسم ذكريه
سببين السبب الاولاني توازن القوى بين
الدولتين السبب التاني الحرب تعمل ايه
يعني انت لما تحارب بتحارب هتاخد قرار
باستخدام القوى العسكريه لك هدف ايه هو
الهدف اللي ممكن الاشتباك العسكري يحققه
ليه الجزائر ويحاول المغرب لم تعد هناك
خلافات حدوديه كل دوله بتقول ان حدودي
مستقره لم تعد هناك في خلافات تانيه لكن
الخلافات التانيه دي لا يحسمها ولا يساعد
عليها اندلاع مواجهات عسكريه
متى تنتهي الحرب في اليمن في تقديري في
تقديرك انا في تقديري ان الحرب في اليمن
اتظل كده صراع مجمد لانه
اطراف مستفيده من استمرار الحرب وما فيش
قوه قادره على
او متحمسه قوي لفكره مواجهه الحوثيين
لا يوجد صوت اصلا
لا يبقى مؤامره ماندو نجحت تماما لا يوجد
صوت اصلا مش هم مغرضين انت اللي صح صح
مش عارف
اهو الراجل رد بالدليل القاطع سمعني الصوت
لا اخونا ممكن يكون الصوت انقطع للحظه بس
شبه جزيره سيناء والمستقبل
يعني لو تحدد السؤال ممكن اسعى للاجابه
يعني
هل سيسمح اجابنا
ما هي اسباب التوتر بين الجزائر والدول
الخليجيه
الجزائر والدول الخليجيه لا انا ما اعرفش
ان في توتر بين الجزائر وبين كل الدول
الخليجيه فانت لو عندك معلومه في قضيه
معينه هو طبعا يعني انا ممكن ابقى فاهم ان
في فطور الجزائر
بتبني سياستها الخارجيه لا تريد علاقات مع
اسرائيل لانه العداء مع اسرائيل احد
السياسات الرئيسيه اللي موجوده للجزائر لا
تريد دعما للمغرب في يعني رغبتها في
التمدد بنفذها في منطقه المغرب العربي لان
اي قوه للمغرب هتكون خصمه من الجزائر لا
تريد دعما خارجيا لقضيه الصحراء بالنسبه
للمغرب في الدول الخليجيه اللي بتعمل كده
بتبقى علاقتها متوتره او ضعيفه او يعني
ودي حاجات بتطلع وبتنزل لكن خلاف ذلك لا
اعلم ان في حاله حاده بين الجزائر ودول
الخليج
هل السدود في تركيا سبب الزلزال الله اعلم
لست عالم يعني جيولوجيا هل طلعوا
هلا طلعوا هل لا تعلقوا هلا طلعوا تعليقي
اذا تحبون الله انا معك اهو ايه التعليقي
اخويا قول ايه التعليق
هل امريكا تتحمل جزء من المسؤوليه عن فشل
الدول العربيه اه تتحمل جزء طبعا بس كل
الدول بتتامر على كل الدول يعني تتحمل اذا
كتبت السؤال للاجابه البسيطه نعم امريكا
لم تسعى في كثير من الاحوال لان دوله
عربيه تنهض ولا تتطور اقتصاديا ولا تتطور
ديمقراطيا ولا ابدا يعني ولم تسعى لغير
الدول العربيه برضو هي بتسعى لافشال الصين
بس انا عاوز اقول لك ان ده مش حاجه خاصه
بالامريكان يعني هي شان الدول كده يعني
يعني مثلا دول كانت لها مصلحه ان هي تنجح
الدول اللي بتحيط بالاتحاد السوفيتي او
بالصين زي السنغافوره مثلا او بتبقى في
نماذج عاوزه زي
[موسيقى]
مثلا
الحرب كانت فين بتاعه الحرب الطويله اللي
هي في الدوله في حرب فيتنام ان هي تساعدها
في التطور لان الدول دي اذا تطورت ونجحت
وبقت علاقتها قويه بامريكا فيما بعد يعني
بعد انتهاء الحروب بتبعدها عن الصين فساعد
لذلك هونج كونج مثلا الى اخره لكن ما كانش
ليه هذه المصلحه في ان هي تساعد الدول
العربيه
خففوا الاسئله يعني نعمل ايه قول وانا
معاك
خففوا الاسئله يعني اعمل ايه يعني هم ما
يسالوش
العدوان الروسي
بوتين الديكتاتور من وضع العالم على حافه
الهويه ده محمد بيقول كده بسبب غزو
اوكرانيا انت بخطئ روسيا دوله فاشله وسلاح
وفاشل
اثبت ذلك انا ماشي خلاص ما انا بحترم رايك
انا هقول لك ايه
انا قلت رايي عشرات المرات انه بس هي
العمليه مش مش صح وغلط هي
يعني هي التصورات انا رايي انه الغرب كان
في غنى عن استفزاز الروس وكان يمكن
انه يتجنب هذه الحرب لا داعي مش انا بس
اللي بقول كده ده عدد كبير جدا من اكبر
الاسماء في السياسه الامريكيه ما فيش داعي
لاستفزاز الروس الى الحد اللي انت تدفعهم
دفعا الى حرب ما فيش داعي لكن عموما
المدام ده رايك انا قلت رايي في عشرات
الحلقات ممكن ترجعوا له لكن الاستاذ محمد
بيقول لي ان ده غلط فكل الاحترام وماله
يعني انا مش بحتكر الحقيقه يعني
هل من الممكن عملنا ده
نريد حلقه اخونا اللي بيقولوا صوت منخفض
لباني يمكن يكون في حاجه عند حضرتك بقى لا
يمكن الصوت حاول تعلي الصوت في مشكله في
المايك لان انا مش
محدش بيشتكي تاني وماندو هو بيقول لي ما
فيش
هنكذب ماندو نريد حل ههه
ابقى
رايك في الاقتصاد المصري مع وجود القياده
السياسيه الحاليه وهل هناك امل الامل
موجود بس هي الازمه الاقتصاديه انت يعني
يعني انا مش عارف ليه الازمه الاقتصاديه
للكلام دايما لما بنتكلم على الازمه
الاقتصاديه بتكون مرتبط بدولتين تلاته
بنتكلم على تونس ومصر
عموما ردا على سؤال حضرتك الامل موجود
ممكن هو الحاجه اللي يعني اللي اتمنى يعني
انه الحكومه المصريه
وهي المساله
كلام بيقول لك
انه يشوفه
انا بقول لان ده صعب بتعمل دايما الحكومه
بتبقى عامله انا اشتغلت سنين طويله في
الجرايد انا ليه بتكلم على الجرايد
الجرنان ده بيتعمل يومي لما تكون في عمل
يومي كل يوم كل يوم او بتعمل برنامج على
التلفزيون او كذا قدرتك على ان انت تبعد
بعيد وتشوف المشهد من بعيد صعب جدا العمل
اليومي كل يوم كل يوم في الحكومه عامله زي
كده انا استدعيت عمل الجرنان لانه بيبقى
عامل زي عمل مجنون
ايقاع سريع جدا توتر شديد جدا تقدر تغطي
الحدث ما تقدرش تجود كانك بتشتغل في مجله
اسبوعيه او شهريه مثلا يعني وكذلك
البرنامج اليومي غير البرنامج الاسبوع
الحكومه
قدامها مهمه صعبه سواء بتقود دوله غنيه او
دوله فقيره
انما اللي اتمناه ان هم يتوفقون ويسالوا
نفسهم السؤال التالي نحن جربنا عده وسائل
وما ادتش الى طفره كبيره بالمناسبه مصر
بالنسبه للدول تانيه تعتبر نموذج جيد يعني
لانه على حسب الزاويه اللي انت هتبص ليها
ناس المركزين قوي قوي على فكره القرود
وارتفاع الاسعار للانصاف الاسعار مرتفعه
في دول اخرى
وللانصاف القروض ايضا موجوده اذا لم يكن
في كل دول العالم فموجود بدرجات كثيره جدا
جدا في دول كثيره غنيه وفقيره
ولكن اما وقد قلنا ذلك ان مصر السؤال
يتقال كده انه يفترض ان امكانياتها تستطيع
ان هي تاخدها لمسافه ابعد شويه تبقى في
وضع اقتصادي افضل شويتين ليه ده ما
بيتحققش ده يحتاج انه الناس تقول ادي اللي
جربناه على مدار السنين وهذا اخذنا الى
هذا الحد لا نطفه ولا نخرق ايه اللي ممكن
نعمله ده سؤال المفروض يتطرح يكون سؤال
صادق ويتطرح على المجتمع بشكل امين وصادق
والحكومه تسمع مش تجيب الناس تتكلم معهم
بس هي اللي تتكلم معهم او تختار الناس
اللي هيوافقوها
فممكن تكون الاجابه افضل كثير يعني لما
الناس
يطلعوا افكار خلاقه ويسمعوها من ناس عندها
خبرات
مش بس ناس عاوزه تقول نعم
استاذنا الكريم معظم القضايا التي تطرحها
تتحدث عنها بحياديه وتجرد تام لكن هل من
الصواب ان تكون حياديه ان نكون حياديين
دائما في كل القضايا حتى في القضايا التي
يكون فيها طرف ظالم لكل
كل مجمع على ظلمه على سبيل المثال
انا اعتقد انه اللي انا انا بصراحه كان في
صديق من من سوريا
مشكورا هو بيدرس في جامعه في فيينا
ومشكورا اهتم هو واستاذه بقناتي اللي هي
نعرف وعمله الدراسه عليها ازاي
الطريقه اللي بيتم نعرف بتتناول فيها او
شخص المتواضع بيتناول فيها القضيه انا انا
بتصرف بتلقائيه انا مش عندي انما هو عمل
ورقه
بحثيه قصيره ومشكورا بعتها لي انما من ضمن
الحاجات اللي لفت نظري انه بينفي عن فكره
القناه فكره الحياديه وبيقول هي مش حياديه
هي موضوعيه
[موسيقى]
بكره علي متاعب كثيره انما الله المستعان
يعني ده انا دماغي كده وبعمل كده وربنا
يعني
هو الحافظ يعني ليه انا عاوز اقول لك على
حاجه يعني بلاش هياخدنا في حاجات شخصيه بس
يعني هذا ما اسعى اليه واتمنى انه يكون
يكون كويس
مدير مناو حضرتك بترغي كتير وما فيش اي
فايده حضرتك
انت عاوز ايه الفايده
حاضر انا هرغي واتمنى اكون في فايده
دمه خفيف مدير مناوب
انا يا صديقي
بعمل حلقه مره في الاسبوع تقريبا وبعمل
حلقه مباشر بناء على رغبه الاصدقاء مره كل
اسبوعين في ناس الله يديهم الصحه والعافيه
بيطلعوا حلقتين
هل بوتين انهزم لا البرق الخاطف لم ينهزم
بعد هل سيسمح اعجبنا
انا ممكن اتوقف على احنا عندنا اسئله
كثيره لسه
انا مش عاوز اتقل على الناس الراجل لسه
بيقول لي انت بترغي كتير وما فيش
فايده السلام عليكم استاذ جبير ممكن جواب
عن وضع هل يمكن للدوله العربيه ان تواجه
مشروع ايران بدون التطبيع مع اسرائيل نعم
ممكن طبعا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا
جدا جدا
يعني لانه ايران دوله زي اي دوله ما تريد
ايران هي من تريد اي دوله وارجع تاني فكره
توازن القوه والدوله لما بتقوى بتتنمر على
غيرها وهكذا انما الدول العربيه تستطيع
وكان في لحظات تقارب مع ايران
وممكن ايران في حاجه الى الدول العربيه
لان عندها اقتصاد مرهق جدا وعاوزه ممكن
التعامل معها مش لازم تتعامل معاه يعني
تامل لها تتعامل معها
وزي ما تعاملنا معها على فترات مختلفه من
الزمان وتفضل برضو تضغط عليها وتضع عليها
تتعاود معها في ملفات وتعاقبها في ملفات
وعاوز اذكرك بحاجه بس من الدول العربيه ما
انت عندك ما هي عندها علاقات جيده مع دول
عربيه عندها علاقات مع الجزائر عندها
علاقات بلاش الجزائر دوله بعيده عندها
علاقات مع سوريا بلاش سوريا عندها علاقات
مع لبنان بلاش لبنان عندها علاقات مع قطر
عندها علاقات مع سلطنه عمان فبرده والدول
اللي هقول لك على حاجه عندها علاقات مع
دوله الامارات فالامارات بتضغط عليها
بتحالفتها مع اسرائيل وامريكا لكن بتتعاون
معاها وترفض ان هي يتم استخدامها لاي
اعتداء على فانت بتتكلم على السعوديه
السعوديه هي انه مش لاقيه قاسم مشترك مع
الايرانيين بتلاقيه احيانا ويعني يذوغ
منها تتبخر لسه كان وزير الخارجيه
الايراني بيتكلم مع وزير الخارجيه العراقي
بيقول نتمنى التطبيع بقى مع السعوديه ومصر
الصوت ممتاز اهو طيب اهو يعني طلع طيبه
بتقول الصوت ممتاز يعني ما فيش مشاكل
الجزائر
هل
هو برضو اخونا اللي انت انا انا بحترم
التعليقات فبراها كلها يعني فاخواني اللي
عمال يكتب الجزائر مقاطعه لفرنسا انا قرات
التعليق والناس اروه وانا مشكورا يعني كل
الاحترام بس يعني التعليقات دي بتعمل يعني
تخلي التعليقات تخرج بره القصه يعني فانا
عموما شاكر لانك انت حريص ان انت تعبر على
رايك هل الصين قدرات عسكريه اكبر من الذي
تظهره لو لو اكتر تظهره كيف اعلمه يعني
لما هي دوله عندها سلاح نووي عندها جيش
عملاق عندها كل انواع التسليح من بايولوجي
وكيماوي وصواريخ عابره
للقارات وعندها كل حاجه عندها كل حاجه
هل الروس قادرون على حرب كبرى ضد هل الروس
قادرون على حرب الكبرى ضد العرب مع تعثرها
في اوكرانيا الروسي حرب العرب ليه يعني ما
السبب يعني هل سيسمح بوتين هل
بوتين ممكن جابنا هل الدولار سينتهي
سيطرته على الاقتصاد انا بحس ان احنا
بنجاوب السؤال ده تقريبا كل على فترات
قصيره الدولار زي ما قلت لحضراتكم قبل كده
هو العمله الاكبر والاهم في العالم الان
وسوف يظل كذلك لعده سنوات لكن بيتراجع
نسبيا يعني
وبتقوى عملات اخرى ما كانش حد ممكن يتخيل
من عشر سنين مثلا انه صندوق النقد اللي
بيعتمد العملات الكبرى في العالم يضمن
الليوان اليها انت ما كانش حاجه متخيله
ابدا يعني اصبح ديوان واحد من عملات
التبادل العالميه ما كانش حد قادر يتخيل
ان البريكس اللي هي الدول الخمسه بتاعه
البريكس وارجعوا لحلقه الب تحبه يبتدوا
يتوسعوا في الاعتماد المتبادل على العملات
المحليه
الصين شغاله في الاطار ده بشكل كبير
وروسيا بسبب الحرب بتضغط جامد جدا جدا على
اضعاف الدولار
والهند معهم الى حد كبير
رايك استاذ سيد ومتى الحرب في اليمن
اجابنا
هل
البرق الخطف مستحوذ على على المباشر
ده صديقك
بس انا حاسس انه ماندو عمال يعني يعملي
يرفع في تعليقات البرق الخاطف وفي ناس
عمال ينزل تعليقاتها معهم
ما هو رايك في التدفق الرهيب للافارقه على
دوله تونس وما هي تدعيه ذلك هم بيتدفقوا
على تونس كمعبر لاوروبا ده حدود معلوماتي
لو عندك معلومه تانيه انت قل لي ده بيحصل
فيه ليبيا بيحصل في دول اخرى ولكن السبب
طبعا الاساسي انه في رغبه في عمليه الهجره
مع المتاعب الاقتصاديه والتغير المناخي
التداعيات كبيره طبعا لان انت بيك ولا
سيدك هي تونس بتعاني ولما يجي لها تدفق
بعشرات الالاف ولا اكتر عمليه مرهقه
اقتصاديا وامنيا وانسانيا
ممكن تتطور الحرب عالميه ممكن بعد التحيه
سؤالي هل في سؤالي في التاريخ هل شهد هل
شهد الفريق الشاذلي عن حرب اكتوبر
وحسب رايك صادقه وتعتبر رؤيه فيها
رحمه الله لا فيها وعليها لانه الفريق
الشاذلي كان عبقريا اللي كان قائد
اركان القوات المسلحه في المصريه في حرب
73 كان عسكريا استثنائيا وكان رجل مثقف
ثقافه عاليه جدا تفتخر به لا يعني تفتخر
به معنى يعني تنبهر انا بتكلم على مستوايا
لما اسمعه بيتحدث في العسكريه وفي امور
غير العسكريه
كان شخصيه تستحق الاعجاب يعني هو خد قرار
في الحرب فيما يتعلق بحدث الثغره ودي قصه
لو اتكلمنا عليها هناخد اليوم كله انما ده
كان ضد راي السادات وعدد من قاده القوات
المسلحه وفيما بعد
انا سمعت من
ضباط لان انا جيشي انا خدمت في مؤسسه كانت
علميه كبيره عسكريه كبيره وده كان من حسن
حظي وده ساعدني ان انا التقي على كبير من
العسكريين المصريين اللي شاركوا في حرب
اكتوبر كتير منهم كان لا يوافق او يعني
كثير مما التقيتهم ما كانش يوافق الفريق
الشاذلي
فعموما هي لها وعليها يعني ده الاجابه
المختصره يعني دي رؤيته للاشياء وبعدين ما
تنساش انه بعد خروجه
وخلافه مع الرئيس السادات كان هو بطبيعه
الانسان كانسان بطبيعه الحال بيستثمر في
وجهه نظره ميقدرش يتخلى عنه لان هو ده كل
كيانه يعني
عبد الرحمن والله فعلا انتظرك حلقات بفارغ
الصبر اولا حيادي ومطلع واسع الثقافه
اشكرك سؤالي هل ايران هل
هو هو ايران توقعاتك الى اين خصوصا مع
شعبها الذي يغلي من عبث اداره ايران
الخارجيه على حساب مقدرات الداخل ايران
بتغلي من سنوات يا صديقي انا طبعا
يعني انا لما سالت حد اثق فيه او اكثر من
حد يعني من حوالي ثلاث شهور كان اجابته
او اجابه اثنين منهم ان في مبالغه شويه في
حجم الغضب اللي موجود يعني ليس بهذه الحده
لكن لا ينكره ان هناك غضب يعني ومع ذلك
الوضع في ايران بيغلي من سنوات
والحكومه دائما حتى الان يعني على مدار من
79 نجحت في اداره امورها في الحرب في
العزله الحصار الى اخره لكن الجديد اللي
انا شايفه قلقان عليه ده يستحق حلقه لانه
في مباشره احنا تقريبا قربنا على الساعتين
الجديد انه يبدو ان اداره بايدن
تعطي رسائل معناها كده انه لا تمانع من ان
اسرائيل توجه عمليات عسكريه زي ما حصل في
29 يناير وما حدث في 29 يناير ضرب اصفهان
مؤشر خطير لانه الولايات المتحده قالت على
حساب مسؤوليه انه احنا متضامنين مع
اسرائيل في عمليه الضرب
فده قد يكون تغيير كبير قد يؤدي الى اتساع
المواجهات العسكريه ويؤدي الاشتعال
المنطقه ده هو الخوف الكبير ده موضوع عاوز
يعني تفاصيل انا اسف ان انا مضطر ان انا
استاذنكم لاسباب يعني انه برضو مش عاوزين
الناس تمل مننا قوي انا عارف ان في كم
اسئله اخرى كثيره بس سامحوني احنا تقريبا
بقى لنا ساعه واربعين دقيقه لا اريد ان
انا
يعني زي ما قال صدقنا كده ارخي كتير وما
فيش فايده اتمنى يكون في فايده واتمنى ما
اكونش صدعتكم انا شاكر جدا جدا وان شاء
الله مع اعتذار الشديد للاسئله التي لم
اجب عنها ان شاء الله ان شاء الله في
المباشر القادم نتناولها شكرا جزيلا جزيلا
وربنا يسعد ليلتكم وكل